in our house you know it wasn't that
politics was something you just kind of
read the paper and oh that's interesting
I mean there was an urgency to it it was
having principled men and women in
office that's how you protect yourself
from tyranny and and so that's what I
wanted to do my whole life
[Music]
hey hey and welcome this is the Ben
Shapiro show Sunday special we're joined
by Senator Ted Cruz we'll get to that in
just a second but first you know what I
hate I hate when people take my data and
then use it to make money off of me
it's my data why are you just taking it
and making money off of me instead you
should join big token it is an app that
you download you share data about
yourself your interest in habits and
then you get paid for it
right now you share an enormous amount
of info with tech companies they make
money off of it you should too that's
where big token comes in here's how it
works first download the app and sign up
for a free big token account next
complete actions to earn points actions
include answering surveys checking into
locations connecting your social
accounts and more then you can redeem
your points for awards like cash gift
cards or you can donate your earnings to
charity if you're a good person you
choose what data you share with big
token and then you get paid for it you
can also get more points for affirming
friends and family your data is always
secure in big token if you want to start
earning money for your data go to the
App Store or Google Play and you search
for big token it's b.i.g Tok en that's
one word download the app and sign up
make sure to use my referral code ben
shapiro again searched big token in the
App Store or Google Play
download the app and use my referral
code ben shapiro to sign up claim your
data and get paid go get big token right
now
senator Cruz thanks so much for stopping
by I really appreciate it great to be
with you Ben so first question where
were you the night of December 20th 1968
you know apparently I was in Northern
California it is amazing the time travel
I mean I was at that point just a
sparkle in my daddy's eyeball but but
but at the time I'm blamed for all sorts
of things I go see a killer joke guys
it's a joke he's not actually dead yet
so I will tell you on the presidential
periodically you'd get college kids that
would come up with a sign saying are you
the zodiac and more than one time I
pulled them aside and said son if I were
really the zodiac would you want to
bring that sign here so let's start from
the premise that you're not the Zodiac
killer and let's talk about your how you
got into politics in the first place so
a lot of people kind of know you from
the last seven eight years since you've
been in the Senate but not everybody
knows kind of your origins story of the
superhero Ted Cruz so senator Cruz where
did you where'd you get started in power
well look I was a science student and I
was bitten by a radioactive spider and
you know the rest of it is history
now grew up in Texas and and for me
politics is my family story
I mean look all of us are products of
our family story and and my dad as you
know my dad fought in the Cuban
Revolution I mean when he was a kid when
he was a teenager he was fighting
alongside Fidel Castro fighting against
Batista who was a corrupt dictator and
and was thrown in prison and he was
tortured
and and my dad came to Texas when he was
just 18 and and I grew up as a kid
hearing stories hearing stories about
being a freedom fighter and it actually
works out my father fought with Castro
didn't know Castro was a communist one
any time I really want to yank my
father's chain I'll call him a communist
guerrilla it drives him nuts what he
knew was that Batista was corrupt he was
in bed with the mob you know Godfather
too you know that whole I mean that was
that was what it was it was a completely
corrupt dictatorship and the revolution
as my dad describes it we're a bunch of
14 and 15 year old kids who didn't know
any better
my dad left in 57 and any fled Cuba
because Batista's army was gonna kill
him
the revolution succeeds in 59 so 59
Castro declares as a communist to begin
seizing people's lands begins executing
dissidents and my aunt might the asagna
who I'm very close to she was still
there she's my dad's kid sister and she
fought in the counter-revolution she
fought against Castro she ended up being
imprisoned and tortured by Castro's
goons and then she she ultimately fled
Cuba to came to Texas and so my cousin
Bibi and I Bibi is Sonja's daughter the
two of us as kids we literally grew up
sitting at the feet of my dad and my
aunt and listening to them tell stories
of a fighting for freedom and and and
that's what I've wanted to do my whole
life for as long as I can remember since
I was a little kid is is in our house
you know it wasn't that politics was
something to just kind of read the paper
and oh that's interesting I mean there
was an urgency to it it was having
principled men and women in office
that's how you protect yourself from
tyranny and and so that's what I wanted
to do my whole life so you ended up
going to law school and then being a
for a while so you kind of moved out of
the wall did you ever want to stay in in
the legal profession you're going to the
judiciary for example you know I enjoyed
being a lawyer I had a fair amount of
success at it and I liked it a lot of my
practice was was arguing in front of the
US Supreme Court and I have to admit of
law practice that's probably the piece I
miss the most
the Supreme Court is it's a unique place
and and it is it is stunningly fast I
mean one of the wild things about the
Supreme Court if you go and visit the
courtroom and you and you know you know
how it is idiot you are surprisingly
close to the justices if you're standing
at the podium is counsel you can almost
reach out and shake hands with the chief
justice the Chief Justice is probably
two feet further away from the council
than you are right now and you have nine
of the most brilliant lawyers and judges
on the planet and and you know an
argument at the Supreme Court it's not
you standing up there giving grand
oratory it is rather you stand up and
say mr. Chief Justice and may it please
the court and and almost immediately the
justices are firing in question just
coming at you from every direction that
was a ton of fun that that's that's
something I miss but but that being said
I'm very glad to be where I am which is
which is in the arena of the Senate and
fighting for issues and in principles
that matter so how did you get into
elective politics you make the move from
the legal profession you decide to run I
believe your first run was against David
Dewhurst uh yeah it was and so Senate
was the first first office I was ever
elected to first the first office you
know I joke when I was elected to Senate
in 2012 the last thing I'd been elected
to before that was student council but
but that's that's really the truth I
mean I I had been the Solicitor General
of Texas which is an appointed position
it's the chief lawyer for the state in
front of the US Supreme Court and I had
done that and then I was a lawyer in
private practice but but when I started
running for Senate the prohibitive
frontrunner was the sitting lieutenant
governor of the state who was worth a
couple hundred million dollars who had
universal name ID who had I mean every
lobbyist every special interest
everybody was with it and and when I
started I mean I was literally at 2%
you know I've joked before the margin of
error was 3% but that's actually not a
joke
we did a poll at the outset of the
campaign to see where things were and
that was those were the first results
was 2 percent support below the margin
of error and in that campaign we just we
ran a grassroots campaign I mean we just
worked around the clock traveled the
state we you know going to forums going
to Tea Party groups going to Republican
Women groups you know and the coalition
that came together it was a incredible
coalition it was young people it was
Hispanics it was it was police officers
and firefighters it was working men and
women and it ended up being a grassroots
tsunami where we can't went from 2
percent to winning the primary by 14
points winning the general by 16 points
and it really was a breathtaking example
of what the grassroots can do when
they're energized and engaged and active
well you came in as kind of the leading
edge of the the Tea Party wave and
obviously at the time there was a lot of
talk about Obamacare a case in which you
became incredibly active what do you
think has sort of happened to the Tea
Party there's been a lot of critiques of
what happened to the Tea Party because
obviously it was primarily driven by
small government concerns Republicans
have been in charge of Congress ever
since or at least in charge of the
Senate virtually ever since and yet the
government is not getting smaller it
continues to grow what do you think
happened to to the Tea Party well I
think the Tea Party made an enormous
difference and and the Tea Party was
part of movements that we've seen in
this country for a long time you know
several years ago I wrote a book called
a time for truth and and each chapter
profiles in the front of it truth teller
someone who stood up often a great risk
and then told the truth and made a
difference one of them one of the truth
tellers that I highlight is Ross Perot
who Ross Perot when he ran against Bush
41 and Bill Clinton I think that he ran
a populist campaign he ran a campaign
that was defending working men and women
and I think actually that Ross Perot
campaign where he got 19% of the vote
nationwide was the initial embers of
what became the Tea Party and it also is
the initial embers of much of
elected Donald Trump in many ways the
biggest divide we've got in Washington
it's not even democrat or republican or
left or right it's socio-economic a
divide between working-class men and
women in this country and and the elites
in Washington in both parties and and I
think for a long time there was a
disconnect the Tea Party was an
expression of that of working men and
women who were fed up fed up with
economic stagnation fed up with lack of
opportunity fed up with with both
parties embracing unchecked illegal
immigration and then looking for real
opportunity I think the Tea Party made a
difference now where are we today well
the last two years we saw some big
victories for economic growth we saw the
biggest tax cut in a generation we saw
job-killing regulations repealed and
we're seeing booming job growth got the
lowest unemployment over 50 years that
has benefited working-class men and
women we're seeing manufacturing jobs
coming back to America for the first
time in a long long time that's a
victory of the tea party um if you look
at Donald Trump's election listen Donald
Trump's election was in many ways a
giant screw you to Washington and and
that that was a frustration with the
career politicians in both parties that
that elected Trump to begin with now
you're right on government spending we
haven't reined it in and and the reality
when it comes to spending is on any big
spending plan you get all of the
Democrats and about half the Republicans
in favor of spending and spending and
spending and so that is going to take
ultimately I think strong presidential
leadership to change it but I do think
what we're we are seeing progress even
though we're not restraining spending we
are seeing progress on the economic
growth side that the tax cuts in reg
reform is a big big part of solving the
problem and then I think beyond that we
need structural solutions we need things
like term limits I'm a passionate
advocate for term limits because it
structurally changes how Washington
works let's talk about term limits first
for a second because yeah I know that
this has become a big talking point on
the right I'm personally pretty
ambivalent about term limits just in the
sense that to me the the final
powers and the people if they feel like
electing a congressperson 11 times I
suppose that that's their their right I
would prefer they not but do you think
that what why do you think that that
restriction is necessary as opposed to
simply saying to the people you know
vote somebody out I mean you took out a
guy who is much more favored in your
Senate race so look I understand that
sentiment and there are times even when
I've I've been pretty amenable to it I
don't think it recognizes the reality
the political process today number one
they're massive advantages with
incumbency incumbency in terms of free
media in terms of money in terms of
infrastructure it's incredibly difficult
to defeat an incumbent but but number
two you know it's interesting I used to
be a supporter of term limits until I
got in the Senate and now I'm a thousand
times more a supporter of tournaments
because what I've seen the dominant
instinct been in the Senate is through
the house also is risk aversion you know
there's an old joke that that politics
is Hollywood for ugly people there's
enormous truth to that you've got old
fat bald guys who were the unpopular
kids in high school who suddenly get
elected to Congress and they go to a
cocktail party and their hands some of
their weedy and they're wise who they
tell a joke and everyone laughs and it
becomes like a narcotic and what happens
is incumbent members of Congress their
dominant focus is I must get reelected
no matter what and so on any big issue
on any big choice if there's a a serious
solution the reasoning often is you know
what if we do that that entails risk and
if there's risk I might not get
reelected if I don't get reelected who
am i and and so one of the big virtues
of term limits is is that it ends the
phenomenon of career politicians I've
introduced I'm the author of a
constitutional amendment in the Senate
to term limits senators to two terms
term limit House members to three terms
and the virtue of that is is that at
least you throw the bums out and bring
new people in and I think you're more
likely to have I hope a Congress that is
responsive to the people because the the
elected officials are not just obsessed
with staying there for life so I'm gonna
go back to the tea party question
just one second because the fact is that
if you look at the left perspective on
the tea party the way that the left
describes the tea party is it was
effectively a racist movement that
disguised itself as a small government
movement in the proof of that is that
once the Republicans took power
there was no move toward small
government at all there was just a move
toward all the other stuff the tax cuts
and maybe some regulatory reform so what
happened to the priorities was it really
just an anti Obama movement or explicit
a principled movement about the growth
of government well look number one
the left's response to everything is
that it's a racist attack that's their
standard they don't want to engage in
ideas they don't engage in substance so
they just scream bigot and anyone who
disagrees with it I mean look I saw on
Twitter recently where someone was
accusing you of being a Nazi or
encouraging that's like the hell are
they talking about maybe that's that's
lunatic fringe stuff but it but it's
mainstream media so you had the tea
party if you have a gathering a rally of
tens of thousands of people you know
what many gathering of tens of thousands
of people you can find one or two with
tinfoil hats who are nuts and if you go
with a TV camera and look you're gonna
find someone who thinks that and that's
who the media focused on they'd go and
find one or two people who are on sort
of the outer fringe and say this is the
whole Tea Party I could tell you who Tea
Party activists were there were regular
people they were working-class men and
women they they weren't the people who
had lobbyists they were they were the
people who you know T stood for taxed
enough already it was a movement that
was focused primarily on taxes on
spending on debt and on economic growth
I do think we've moved away from some of
the corruption of Washington from some
of the swamp and I think the Trump
administration has been positive in that
regard it's still the case that
government keeps growing and growing but
you know look one of the things the
media never covers we passed a major tax
cut in December of 2017 federal tax
revenue since that tax cut have gone up
in other words the federal government is
taking more money in more revenues in
with lower tax rates now now that
doesn't surprise you and it doesn't
surprise me
in part because
we know something about history if you
look back JFK campaigned on cutting
taxes he cut taxes in office and federal
tax revenues went out Ronald Reagan
campaigned on cutting taxes he cut taxes
in office and federal revenues went up
now the reason that the deficit and the
debt keeps growing is that spending is
growing even beyond that but but I do
think the first piece of it the economic
growth is important and and I'm gonna
continue fighting for both pieces of it
so in one second I wanna ask you about
the possibilities of some form of
entitlement reform because Republicans
talk a lot about it and then ya seem not
to do much about it yeah but first
there's a widely held belief the
procrastination is a bad thing but life
isn't so black and white sometimes
procrastination can work in your favor
for example if you need life insurance
but you've been putting it off
congratulations
you actually procrastinated yourself
into technology that makes it easy
policy genius is the easy way to shop
for insurance online in just two minutes
you can compare quotes from top insurers
and find your best price once you apply
the policy genius team will handle all
the paperwork and the red tape no sales
pressure no hidden fees just financial
protection and peace of mind and policy
genius doesn't just make life insurance
easy they also help you find the right
home insurance auto insurance disability
insurance so if you need life insurance
but you've been busy doing literally
anything else check out policy genius
it's the easy way to compare all the top
insurers and find the best value for you
policy genius com nobody wants to shop
for life insurance that's why policy
genius made it easy also just go be an
adult you know you're an adult that
means you got to take care of your
family make sure that they're taken care
of in case god forbid something should
happen to you policy genius makes it
super easy it's not gonna take a ton of
time and you take care of your family
what's better than that go check them
out right now at policy genius com and
never think about life insurance again
once you get it taken care of policy
genius.com alrighty so let's talk about
entitlement reform so Republicans are
constantly talking about we needs a
reform entitlement 66% of our spending
is Medicare Medicaid Social Security
everybody knows this stuff everybody
knows that we're gonna bankrupt
ourselves within the next fifteen years
if we do nothing about it and yet it
seems like there's very little taste for
this including at the presidential level
president Trump said in 2016 has no
interest in touching entitlements do you
basically see this as just a train that
we are going to drive into Eastwood
Gulch I mean is now is that where we are
going or is there a possibility of jail
look I think to see real entitlement
reform we're going to have to see
leadership from the top and you're right
Donald Trump didn't campaign on
entitlement reform and
and he doesn't seem focused on leading
in this regard without that it's not
going to happen
I think ultimately it's critical to the
solution I'm you know two-thirds of the
federal spending or our entitlement
programs or mandatory spending that grow
we can eliminate everything else and
that still doesn't solve the problem of
course we're not going to eliminate
everything else I will say also I think
it's possible to engage and engage
proactively on entitlement reform up so
for example for a lot of years
let's take Social Security Social
Security was treated as the third rail
of politics you touch it you get
electrocuted well I can tell you in 2012
when I got elected to the Senate the
first time I campaigned on in 2018 I
campaigned on it and and I think what
politicians in Washington are doing
right now is irresponsible both parties
because they're allowing Social Security
to careen towards insolvency and I think
it is a critical bulwark that that
millions of Americans rely on so how do
we reform it for specific principles
number one seniors those on Social
Security or near retirement no changes
at all nothing zero not a penny we've
made promises people have counted on it
they've ordered their financial affairs
we need to honor those promises but but
for young younger workers people you're
at my age it is hard to find someone in
their 30s or 40s who believes Social
Security will be there for us that's an
incredible opportunity to for reform if
we've got a generation who understands
this is headed towards insolvency three
critical reforms for younger workers
number one gradually increased the
retirement age
when Social Security was enacted life
expectancy was much much less people are
working a lot longer gradually increase
the retirement age for younger workers
and give us time to plan on it and
arrange our finances accordingly number
two change the rate of growth of Social
Security benefits so that so that it
matches inflation instead of exceeding
inflation those two changes bring Social
Security and solvency but the third
change for younger workers I think is is
the most important allow younger workers
to keep a portion of our tax payments in
a personal account that we own that we
control that we can invest and the end
that we can use in addition
to the retirement payment and that we
can pass on to our kids and grandkids
that that is transformative it is
something I've been fighting for since I
arrived in the Senate I intend to keep
fighting for so I want to talk about the
kind of future of the Republican Party
from from two particular angles I want
to talk about it from the conservative
angle like where the attacks are coming
from on the right and where the attacks
are coming from on the left so let's
start with the right it seems like at
least in 2016 there was this emerging
gap between the quote/unquote populist
conservatism of President Trump and sort
of the classical old-school conservatism
that you were representing in the 2016
race and in the end it seemed as though
the populist conservatism was was
ascended I never really bought into the
idea the populist conservatism was an
ideology it seemed like more of an
effect to me and in terms of policy
president Trump has basically governed
like a conservative with the absence of
any sort of spending cuts do you think
that there is such a thing as populist
conservatism and how much how much I
guess attention should be paid to the
prevarications of people who say that
the future of the Republican Party lives
and things like tariffs and government
involvement and subsidies and all that
sort of stuff you know look I do think
there is such a thing as populism but
but but I'm gonna a little bit fight the
hypo and then reject the
characterization I you know I'm very
much a Reagan conservative but I think
Reagan was a populist if you look at
free-market principles they are all
about working men and women they are all
about opportunity they're all about
folks like my dad when he came from Cuba
with nothing having an opportunity he
washed dishes making 50 cents an hour
but he was in an economic environment
where you could climb that economic
ladder and and so you know if you look
at 2016
we've talked a little bit earlier about
the socio-economic divide 2016
Republican field there were 17
Republicans running and and if you were
laying odds in DC or New York at the
beginning of the campaign who was gonna
be the nominee who was gonna win the
election nobody would have bet on Donald
Trump and actually nobody would have bet
on me either we might have been 16 and
17 in the betting odds there were a
bunch of other candidates that were
supposed to be the dominant juggernauts
if you fast-forward of the primaries if
you look at almost every state and if
you look at working-class voters
working-class voters in almost
every state either Trump was one and I
was 2 or I was one and he was 2 and it
is almost perfectly correlated the
states where I was one and he was 2
among working-class voters are the 12
states I won the states where he was one
and I was two or the states he won and
none of the other 17 candidates won more
than a single state Kasich won Ohio
Rubio won Minnesota and Trump and I won
the other 48 now that utterly upended
Washington conventional wisdom but the
reason that happened I believe is
because Washington politicians both
Democrats and Republicans were not
responding to the Ohio steel workers to
the truck drivers to the waitresses to
the to the cops and firefighters to the
men and women with calluses on their
hands so when I hear populism that's
what I think about is who are you
fighting for and and look big government
and socialism the Democrats fight for
the elites for the special interest
under Obama the rich got richer big
government and big business do great
together because big business gets in
bed with big government Miami you listen
I'm very skeptical a big business I'm
interested in small businesses I'm
interested in the next generation of
creative destruction and entrepreneurs
and so I think breaking the corporatist
cronyism of Washington was a very
important issue in 2016 and those same
working-class voters by the way that
decided the 2016 primary are also the
voters who won the general election who
gave Trump the victory over Hillary
Clinton so I think in that regard now
that doesn't mean as the media pundits
want to say that you suddenly have a
whole dramatically new agenda if you
look at what Trump is actually enacted
I've worked very closely with the
President on this tax cuts repealing
job-killing regulations securing the
border rebuilding the military those are
conservative values but they respond to
the working men and women in this
country so the these sort of left-wing
critique of republicanism is that if you
look at let's say the 2016 primaries
where you're finishing high and Trump is
finishing high and you look at your
economic theories your economic theories
are very dissimilar you you went into
Iowa and what I thought was an
incredibly brave move you said no more
subsidies for ethanol which in Iowa is
basically political suicide then you
proceeded to win Iowa
whereas President Trump went in there
and basically said look at senator Cruz
he's the one out there saying that or
lyin Ted as he put it and he's the one
out there saying that you know he's
gonna take away your subsidies so in
other words you guys were sort of at
odds on economics so putting in the same
basket economically the critique of the
media and the left would say is is not
supremely accurate what they would say
is that this is a culture war issue that
basically there are a lot of people in
the middle of the country who were sick
of being disrespected at the by the
media elites on both coasts who had
treated them as the great unwashed
masses and that you were giving them
respect and President Trump was giving
them respect that's the nice way of
putting it from the left the bad way of
putting it from the left is that is
obviously that all these unwashed masses
are in fact unwashed masses and that you
unified them because there was a covert
racism to to your campaign or to
president Trump's campaign that gets
back to what we were saying earlier but
it does raise a question which is how
can the Republican Party reach out
beyond it sort of traditional
constituency I know there's a lot of
talk about this leading up to 2016
obviously you're Hispanic senator
Rubio's Hispanic there was a lot of talk
about this kind of the new faces of the
Republican Party and then the guy who
wins the presidency is is he a 70 year
old white guy from New York and so
there's a lot who was making some
appeals that that were certainly you
know controversial to say the least
what do you make of that critique and
how does the Republican Party move into
new audiences well I think first of all
I remember down at South Carolina right
before the South Carolina primary I was
doing a media gaggle and one reporter
asks that what do you do about the fact
that the Republican Party are a bunch of
old white guys and I just started
laughing at this it excuse me have you
looked at if you looked at the field we
we have an african-american world famous
physician we have Carly Fiorina a
fortune 50 CEO we have two sons of Cuban
immigrants both both in both in their
early to mid 40s compare that to the
Democratic parties like that 70 shows
you had a bunch of septuagenarians
battling it out and by the way fast
forward to today it seems now they're
they're you know octogenarians by the
way if all of these folks can run want
one word i'll say to our democratic
friends you know jimmy carter still
alive only served one term i mean if
they're if they're going for yesteryear
i think they need to recruit
Jimmy Carter look the Democratic Party
is a throwback to old and failed ideas
and they're galloping that way now one
of the challenges we have is we have a
one of the great virtues of the age of
Trump is his fake news has been exposed
you know you remember a few years ago
people used to argue oh the media isn't
biased nobody argues that anymore I mean
they're so plainly unhinged you watch
the these reporters foaming at the mouth
you watch these networks that they hate
Trump so much now listen you and I both
had our disagreements with Donald Trump
but but you look at just the naked
irrational hatred of the media left
directed at Trump and and that is
revealing of who they are now the
challenge is and this is that this is a
challenge for you and for me and for
everyone it is to get folks that are not
living and breathing this everything get
young people and Hispanics and African
Americans and suburban moms to
understand and focus on the substance
and the issues these policies matter
listen if you're a young person it
matters when you come out of school
whether you have booming economic growth
and lots of job opportunities or whether
you move into your parents basement
because the economy is so stagnant as it
was under the Obama years that you can't
get a job but we've got to communicate
it we've got to get it around the the
media filters that don't want anyone to
hear that truth so what sort of message
do you pervade there so one of the
things that's been fascinating to me I'm
from California
the Republican Party has been
eviscerated among Hispanic voters in
California that is not what has happened
in Texas in Texas
what is it a 55/45 or 60/40 split in
favor of Democrats but it's certainly
competitive with Republicans here at
something like 8020 in favor of
Democrats if that it maybe higher so
what has been done in Texas what have
you done in your races to help draw
Hispanic voters so look in Texas in 2012
I got 40% of the Hispanic vote in 2018 I
got 42% of the Hispanic vote and then
and that is despite the media
demagoguing like crazy and listen I
think the Hispanic community is a
fundamentally conservative community if
you look at the values in our community
that resonate faith family patriotism
hard work you know a friend of mine
years ago asked interests
in question he said when's the last time
you saw an Hispanic panhandler gonna
tell you I don't think I ever have
because frankly in Hispanic culture
would be seen as be shameful to be out
there on the streets begging and yet you
look at hard work individual
responsibility and and it those are
conservative values and you also look at
what unifies the Hispanic community
which is the immigrant experience coming
to America seeking freedom that is a
message that resonates but I'll tell you
I had the exact same message in the Rio
Grande Valley and overwhelmingly
Hispanic communities that I had in deep
East Texas and and the message of jobs
and freedom and security that's a
message that resonates now listen
California is a special place I'll tell
you it's interesting when I'm out in
California
I'll get together with conservatives
with Republicans and and it's almost
like like conservatives in California
are beaten down I'll tell you a point
though that a lot of people don't know
you know what state has the most
Republicans by numbers we do I mean
state populous state yeah there are more
Republicans in California than there are
in Texas every California Republican
eyes tell that to is shocked and amazed
now there are even more Democrats I'm
not saying that conservatives are not
outnumbered here but a lot of the
California conservatives and Republicans
are just beaten down they don't believe
that they can change the state politics
but look I think the Hispanic community
is a conservative community but we've
got to respond to the needs and interest
in values in the Hispanic community if
you look right now today we have the
lowest Hispanic unemployment ever
recorded we've also got the lowest
african-american unemployment ever
recorded now the clown show that is the
Democratic 2020 primary none of them are
going to admit that they're gonna go to
Hispanics and african-americans that are
seeing the lowest unemployment every
record and they're gonna say these
policies are terrible for you you should
go back to the Obama era policies where
you had much higher unemployment much
higher poverty that is nonsense let me
give you one of my favorite stats the
last two and a half years the last two
and a half years
five million people came off of food
stamps five million and and look as
Republicans we've got to be able to
articulate that and explain it in a way
that that's not just a number on a pie
chart those are five million real human
beings those are moms and dads the two
and a half years ago they were dependent
on the federal government for the basic
food needs who now presumably they've
gotten a job they're coming home tonight
they're carrying a bag of groceries
they're setting it down on the kitchen
table and those moms and dads are
looking their kids in the eyes they're
having the dignity of work the
self-respect of work that is what the
American Dream is all about being able
to provide for your family achieve your
dreams but we've got to communicate and
tell you this panic community that is a
powerful message Hispanics don't want to
be dependent on government and what what
what the Socialists what the Democrats
say is they want them to be dependent on
government they want them to be a vassal
dependent state vote for Democrats and
be trapped in dependency
what I what I know Hispanics want is the
independence to chase their dreams that
is a conservative message so you're
somehow able to defeat the second coming
himself the greatest candidate in the
history of American politics beta
O'Rourke whose skateboarded in from the
heavens well apparently not smoking a
doobie was shocking to me but but a
parent and then you defeated him and
relegated him to eating dirt and then he
actually did this he went to New Mexico
and he ate ceremonial dirt and then he
decided to run for president apparently
the dirt didn't do him any good because
the media have fallen out of love with
Beto's so to me this is a media story
they created him from nothing and now
they have sent him back to the dust from
once he but what what is what is your
take on how that race went and how much
of that was just media hype what listen
I think he is a talented politician I
also think that the heart of his base
was the media who were just enthralled
with him that there was I think a macro
in every stir if you're writing a beta
profile it automatically populated with
with the adjectives kennedy-esque in
fact I think your publisher wouldn't
wouldn't your editor wouldn't publish it
without Kennedy asked they talked about
his hair and his teeth and his smile and
it was just it actually read like like
you know
Teen Vogue I I mean it was talking about
the latest heartthrob um and look at yet
Inc complicated if you're a leftist
journalist and you could beat one
Republican in the country was on the
ballot in 2018 it'd be me you know you
and I are not supposed to exist
you're an Orthodox Jew who is not a hard
leftist that that from from their
perspective how dare you embrace a
different view I'm Anna spanic son of an
immigrant who believes in freedom and
believes in conservative values that
drives the left out of their mind
and so you saw the media just rush in
with this glowing adulation now you can
trace the point that changed and it was
the day after the general election when
suddenly bado is not running against me
but is running against a bunch of other
leftist is running against Bernie
Sanders is running against Kamala Harris
and the media turned I I mean it it is
stunning I mean they turned out here is
a classic illustration Reuters in 2017
had evidence that O'Rourke was part of a
hacker cult as a teenager and may have
committed multiple felonies they went
and interviewed Reuters interviewed beta
in 2017 he admitted it all said yep yep
I did that and Reuters said I'll tell
you what we will embargo this we won't
publish it for a year and a half we
won't publish it until after the
November 2018 election because you know
everyone knows we got to do everything
we can to beat Cruz after that will
publisher so they came out now you know
the the sort of weird fan fiction he
wrote as a kid the the bizarre stuff
like fantasizing running over children
all of that came from Reuters is
reporting that they just sat on they put
on ice for a year and a half until after
the election now what do you think of
the odds been if they had evidence that
I'd committed multiple felonies that
they'd say gosh we'll just sit on it for
a year and a half and not publishing it
it's this is in fact the best proof that
you're not the Zodiac killer because if
you were there's no question that would
have uncovered this and and brought it
out against you true
okay so what let's talk for a second
about sort of your image as portrayed by
the media over the course of your career
so you start off you win the stunning
victory against david Dewhurst I
remember I was there I remember you
coming from nowhere to win this victory
against a very heavily favored opponent
and then you start kind of climbing the
ranks in a sense that you were getting
all sorts of media attention you're
you're giving speeches on the Senate
floor and then came the point where it
seemed like the world turned against you
and that was when you decided to
filibuster the Obamacare vote where he
got up and he started talking about how
the Republican majority leader had
failed to stop Obamacare properly what
was your motivation for doing that I
know that the take from from cynical
politico's was that it wasn't gonna be
effective so it's basically you just
grandstanding and then there's the take
from from other conservatives who are
basically saying no somebody has to
stand up and do this or it's gonna get
funded it's never gonna go away why did
you do that
look I did it for two reasons number one
Obamacare was going into effect and once
it went into effect it was going to
prove incredibly difficult to unwind and
number two I had promised the people of
Texas I told the voters of Texas in 2012
I said if you elect me I will fight with
every ounce of strength in my body I
will lay in front of a speeding train to
stop this disaster that is Obamacare
that was a promise and and so what I
endeavored to do each and every day and
I still do is keep those promises you're
right the media pound of the heck out of
me Republican leadership pounded the
heck Adam II the Left pounded the heck
out of me but to be honest I really
don't give a flip and part of it is
because I try to remember who I'm
working for
you know I remember back in 2012 I
remember a little old lady up in East
Texas grabbed me by the shoulder she
said Ted please don't go to Washington
and become one of them
um you know in many ways being elected
with with a grassroots movement it's
liberating because when I was elected
every lobbyist in the state was against
me just about every major corporation
was against me every major trade
association was against me that means
I'm not holding any
that what I am beholden to are the truck
drivers and oil field workers and and
college kids and all the working men and
women who knocked on doors who worked
their hearts out and and so I tried to
on every decision say alright how would
I explain it to the men and women that I
sat in town hall after Town Hall after
Town Hall with and when it came to
Obamacare what what Republican
leadership was content to do is do
nothing that was not acceptable and I
and I'll tell you you know in the middle
of that that Obamacare filibuster where
I spoke for 21 hours and the Senate
floors the phone's lit up millions of
phone calls went into Congress
Republican leadership hated that because
the because the American people said we
don't want this disaster that is
Obamacare if you remember the Wall
Street Journal didn't did an editorial
where it called me the minority maker
said Ted Cruz is gonna single-handedly
keep Harry Reid as Majority Leader now
if in the 2014 election Republicans had
been decimated and Harry Reid of
remained majority leader how quick do
you think all those media pundits all
that Republican leadership would have
been to victory lap and said AHA see we
told you
this fight is destroying our majority
which they said every day in 2014
Republicans won nine seats in the US
Senate we've retired Harry Reid as
Majority Leader and we won the biggest
majority in the House since I believe in
1928 and not a one of the folks in
leadership thought gosh maybe the fact
that we were standing up and fighting on
Obamacare and finally doing something
and finally trying to honor our promise
maybe that has something to do with
people showing up and voting I think the
way you win elections look the
Washington conventional wisdom is you
win elections by standing for nothing by
getting along and going along I think
the way you win elections by giving
people a reason to vote by standing and
saying look we're going to follow
through and do what we said we would do
that gives people a reason to go knock
on doors that gives people a reason to
make phone calls you know 2016 in in the
presidential race my campaign
326,000 volunteers knocking on doors
making phone calls sending emails to get
as a way of perspective the Hillary
Clinton campaign talked about their
target for the general election was ten
thousand volunteers with three hundred
twenty six thousand we ended up raising
over ninety two million dollars which is
the most money any Republican has ever
raised in a presidential primary in
history that came from one point eight
million contributions that's what
happens when you actually just you just
do what you said you would do none of
this is rocket science it's actually why
look there's some Republicans who run in
their states as moderates for those
Republicans I'm not mad at them when
they vote as moderates think that's
honest I may disagree with him on a
policy issue but if they tell the voters
here's where I stand and then if they
vote that way art that's democracy what
I think the voters resent is those same
people that were blasting me when
they're out campaigning they tell people
I'm just like it and then they get to
Washington said I don't know let's not
actually do what we said we would to and
look when Trump astonished the media
class astonished Washington by winning I
think it was right at the heart of the
American people fed up with people in
Washington not doing what they said and
then they believed this guy is gonna
blow up Washington and I think we've
seen some good results not all good
results but a lot of good results is
because of it so you run this very
knock-down drag-out race with President
Trump honestly you have a lot more
wherewithal than I would have I mean he
attacked you as lyin Ted he attacked
your father he suggested that he was
involved in the assassination of John F
Kennedy
he attacked your wife and and you kind
of took all of it in he was calling you
lines and now you're beautiful Ted so
how exactly did that how exactly did
that relationship shift in morph over
time look you can't take any of this
personally
you have to have a thick skin and it is
I guess a virtue in politics or the
media to be able to be whacked in the
head with a stick and keep on going then
I like what Trump said in the primary
now that being said he
not the first person to have thrown
insults to me he's not the last person
that's that's the environment we live
and I try not to respond in kind
you don't see me vilifying and insulting
the character of others whether
Republicans or Democrats I engage with
the mind on ideas I'll talk to you about
why Bernie Sanders ideas are terrible
but I you know I I don't I don't play
that way you know when it came November
2016 when Trump won I faced a choice at
that time it would have been easy to
have my feelings hurt there there it is
very difficult to find something that
will piss me off more than going after
my family so I was not happy about that
job to do I'm elected to represent 28
million Texans and and and if I had
taken my marbles and gone home I
wouldn't be doing my job and and so you
know look I got on a plane I flute flew
to New York went to Trump Tower the week
after the election in November and I
said mr. president this is an historic
opportunity we've got both houses of
Congress and the White House we've got
to deliver on our promises and I told
him that I said mr. president I want to
do everything humanly possible to help
bring Republicans together so we can do
what we said we would do that affinity
that's why I ran for Senate I believe
this stuff I believe in low taxes low
regulation I believe in Liberty I
believe in the Constitution these
principles work and and and if we had
wasted that window of opportunity it
would have been a tragic missed
opportunity that might never come again
by the way if you're given control of
both houses of Congress and the White
House and you blow it and do nothing
nobody would fault the voters for saying
you know why vote for these clowns they
don't do anything we at least in the two
years we had it we delivered a great
deal I wish we delivered more and I was
pressing very hard to deliver more but
I'm really grateful for everything we
did deliver and and so that's why I work
with the president I don't like
everything he says I wish she would say
some different things and do some stairs
different things but I do like the
policy victories that we've won for the
people of Texas and the American people
in the booming economy and the improved
national security that we're seeing are
both direct results of that so I don't
turn you into political pundit but I
would be remiss cuz I've been asking
everybody this and I think everybody's
asking this how do you think that the
2020 race goes because you know from my
perspective the president's got a very
good record he's got a lot to run on at
the same time he says things that
alienate vast swaths of the American
population where do you think this is
going in 2020 listen I'm worried about
in 2020
I think it's 50/50 I think it's a coin
flip I think the country is deeply
divided it is an incredibly polarized
country and I think it all comes down to
turnout I think the left is going to
show up in massive numbers and it all
comes that down to who shows up on the
center-right if conservatives stay home
if working-class voters stay home we
could seek devastating losses week we
could see losing the White House and
losing the Senate with massive harm to
the country as a result on the other
hand if we turn people out we could have
a great victory we could retake the
house and and and and and hold hold the
White House and have the president
re-elected you know I actually think a
very good crystal ball for 2020 is what
happened in 2018 in particular in Texas
in 2018 so if you look at the Texas
Senate race where the media was all in
beta or or crazed over 80 million
dollars he outspent us three to one
now some people say you know it's
interesting I hear sometimes
oh come on money doesn't matter in
politics really you typically hear that
people have never run for office because
money is the tool by which you
communicate particularly when the media
is all in on the other side let me give
you one example of how money matters in
politics my campaign in 2018 had 18 full
time campaign staffers baito O'Rourke's
campaign had 805 18 to 805 try any other
battle with that kind of mismatch in
terms of resources and and what ended up
happening the Democrats increase their
turnout in the state of Texas more than
100 percent 1.8 million Democrats showed
up in 2014 the last off-cycle election
1.8 million this time around
four million Democrats showed up they
increased from 1.8 million to 4 million
now thankfully what we did is we turned
out 4.2 million Republicans and that
point to was the entire margin of
victory now how did we do that part of
it was at the end I did a barnstorming
tour of the state got in a bus and we
did 50 town halls and rallies in the
last six weeks all over the state and
and rang the bell and said to any
common-sense conservatives in Texas if
you want to see low taxes low
regulations lots of job if you want the
border secure if you want the
Constitution and the Bill of Rights
protected show up in public I think
that's exactly what we're gonna see in
2020 every leftist in the country is
gonna show up and they're gonna crawl
over broken glass they hate Donald Trump
with a white-hot passion you're gonna
see Democrats in areas you didn't know
there were any Democrats there they're
gonna crawl out of the Woodworks which
means we've got to give everyone else a
reason to show up and vote and this is
where the DC instincts are so dangerous
because if the DC Republicans say oh
it's a close election let's stand for
nothing let's just just let's not do
anything let's not have any fights let's
avoid standing for anything that's how
you depress the voters and that's how
you lose the election the way instead we
win 2020 as we give people a reason to
vote we stand for big bold you know
Reagan used to say paint in bold colors
not pale pastels I think that's the key
to winning the election so let's talk
about Texas Arizona another state where
we are seeing movement toward the purple
in Texas obvious that's been at the top
of Democrats list the reason that yours
Harrogate number one is because they saw
that as indicator that they could
finally turn this kind of deep red state
blue do you think that Texas is moving
in the direction of the blue it looks
right now like a lot of folks are moving
into Austin a lot of folks moving into
urban areas that are much more to the
left the voting the voting records tend
to show by more Democratic turnout is
Texas in danger of turning purple
absolutely I think Texas is a
battleground and you know they're too
broad there are a lot of different
movements going on but too broad
political movements that are
cross-cutting one thing we're saying in
recent years is working-class voters are
moving right that's making states like
Midwestern states trend more Republican
what we're also saying however is
suburban voters in particular suburban
women are trending left that means
states with big suburban population
states like Texas states like Georgia
states like Arizona are trending left
they're becoming more purple
you know Texas people think of Texas as
a rural state you know the sort of the
cowboy ethos but we're one of the most
urban and suburban states in the entire
country three of the ten biggest cities
in America are in the state of Texas and
four of the eleven biggest cities in
Texas are in the country are in Texas in
Texas between Houston Dallas Fort Worth
Austin and San Antonio over two-thirds
of the voters in the state of Texas are
in those those four major metro areas we
have massive suburban populations
basically the way the Texas voting
typically works is you have the cities
which have been democratic for a while
the core of the cities and then you've
had these bright red doughnuts around
the cities that have been submerged is
what's kept Texas solidly Republican
well what happened in 2018 is those
bright red doughnuts became purple as
suburban voters moved heavily left by
the way that's what decimated the
congressional Republicans in in
California California has a lot of
suburban voters as well places like
Orange County that used to be very
Republican and they moved significantly
to the left if we're gonna stay
competitive we've got to be reaching
those suburban moms and making the case
why these policies matter why why
socialism and open borders why that is
bad for for suburban moms why that's bad
for your kids why that's bad for your
future the media doesn't want any of
those messages to get across and and so
that means it's our job and and we've
got to do it in ways that get around the
gatekeepers because the gatekeepers
they're not pretending to be Walter
Cronkite anymore
they are full-on partisans they will put
on their hat and they will cheer for
whatever leftist wins the Democratic
nomination and they will do everything
they can to collate the information and
to
in a propaganda war for those of us who
value freedom we've got to counteract
that so if you look in the Democratic
field is there anybody in the Democratic
field who you find particularly scary
for the general election as opposed to
the other candidates I think the
Democrats are going to nominate someone
from the far left you know right now Joe
Biden's having a moment I don't think
Biden will be the nominee because all of
the energy all of the passion in the
Democratic Party is on the extreme left
I think it's likely it's probably one of
four people that it that it is Bernie
Kamala Harris bado
or Elizabeth Warren and maybe I throw
mayor Pete into that he's kind of having
a moment he's stolen some abidos thunder
I think the nominee is likely to come
from from that group because that's
where the fire is now some on the right
conservatives when I say something like
that think oh great okay those guys are
so loony of course we win that ain't the
case at all listen the terrifying thing
is I think America is entirely capable
of voting for on on abashed wild-eyed
socialist we are divided 180 thousand
votes which in 2016 and Hillary
Clinton's the president this country is
divided on a Razors inch and so that
means we've got a job to do
you know between those candidates I
think Bernie and Warren are the least
good at hiding just how out there they
are
I think Harris and bado and and Mayor
Pete to some extent are better at
seeming reasonable while embracing
lunatic left positions but whoever
whoever the Democrats nominate
I believe will be formidable because
everyone left of center is showing up in
2020 their base to be honest their
turnout tool is Donald J Trump in the
race against bado
they don't rarely mention mine
you didn't run against me you're ranting
it's Donald Trump in this election
that's gonna turn their base out now the
good news is if we turn just
center-right voters out people who
believe in common sense that's how we
win but we got to turn him out so I want
to ask you about sort of the checks and
balances in the system so one of the
critiques of the Republican Senate
particularly and the Republican Congress
more generally when the Republicans held
the house was that they were delegating
too much authority to the executive
branch I thought for a very long time
that that the legislature is becoming a
vestigial organ of American government
everything is being done by
bureaucracies and that the Senate and
the Congress are deeply unwilling to
take back any of these statutorily and
constitutionally granted powers they're
grants it's take an example when it
comes to trade Authority the idea of
delegating one way trade authority to
the executive branch and then not being
able to pull it back right when it comes
to the making of war not pulling back
any of that authority what do you think
about the possibility of Congress at any
point in the future starting to take
back some of that power look I hope we
do I'm a big believer in revitalizing
article one having Congress take the
responsibility to be accountable to the
people again there's strong structural
incentives that Congress doesn't want to
do it it's much easier to to kick the
responsibility over to the unelected
regulators you know last year in 2018 I
made a very hard pitch to Republican
leadership I made a very hard pitch to
the White House that we should take up
on other budget reconciliation now
you'll recall budget reconciliation is
the procedural tool that we used in 2017
to pass the tax cut the only thing
that's relevant for this discussion is
that budget reconciliation can't be
filibustered it only takes 50 votes to
pass so the Democrats can't stop it and
I urge we should take up a budget
reconciliation in 2018 win some more
victories and and therefore things in
particular that I said we should do
number one we should build a wall fully
funded we could have done it with only
Republican votes the Democrats could not
have stopped us number two we should
have made the individual tax cuts in the
small business tax cuts permanent both
of those are set to sunset we could have
made in permanent forever number three
we should have passed what I call the
Obamacare consensus reforms
in the Senate last year we didn't have
fifty votes for a total repeal
tragically I fought hard for that but we
had fifty votes for a lot of the reforms
that would have increased competition
increased choices and lowered premiums
for working men and women that would
have been a great victory and then
number four this goes right to your
question is that I urge we should pass
what's called the reins Act the reins
Act would be the most sweeping
regulatory reform ever passed by
Congress it would say that no economic
regulation can go into effect unless it
receives an affirmative up/down vote
from Congress if its impact on the
economy would be a hundred million
dollars or more we could have done that
with only Republicans the Democrats
would have screamed they would have
yelled but they couldn't have stopped us
now I made that case I did a long
powerpoint to all the Republican
senators I pitched it over and over and
over again for the last six months of 18
I made that case directly to the
president I made that case the vice
president I made that case the chief of
staff at the end of the day Republicans
didn't do it and and and frankly the
answer as to why was never never very
satisfied it's just now it's too hard
it's not worth it I don't understand why
we had a golden opportunity yes we've
accomplished a lot but if we had taken
up those victories it would have been
truly transformation on the only thing
lacking was the understanding of how to
do it and the willingness to actually
stand and fight you know that's kind of
an example of where I said the
Washington instinct is oh we got an
election let's not take on anything
consequential what I urged the president
and Republican leadership I said you
know what let's do this imagine if we
had done this in October October of last
year we're fully funding building a wall
on the entire border you've got
Elizabeth Warren screaming on the Senate
floor you've got Bernie pulling his hair
out you got the media going crazy and we
have the votes and get it done imagine
how many Americans show up to say my god
these people actually made a promise
that they did what they said we might
very well I believe have held the house
not made Nancy Pelosi speaker if we had
taken up that fight and won that fight
and gotten another victory
but unfortunately the the leadership
wasn't willing to do that what do you
what do you fear most I mean right now
there's the possibilities you say a
50/50 shot that the President Trump
loses the presidency if that happens
then Democrats have at least a decent
shot at taking in the Senate what is
what is the proposal that you see from
the Democrats that you fear the most
right now that they're pushing look to
be honest it's all of the above if
Democrats win the White House there is a
very good chance they win the Senate as
well if that happens if they have
control over both houses of Congress and
the White House I think their objective
will be to try to make structural
changes to make their right rule
perpetual so what will that mean that
will mean a number of things number one
all right let's start economically tax
cuts immediately repealed but we're not
going back to the status quo ante I
think they will jack up taxes
dramatically particularly if they get
elected on the angry howl of socialism
just think for a moment you got
Democrats talking about seventy percent
tax rate or higher I think you'll see
those policies pass by the way I believe
if Democrats take the White House in the
Senate they will end the filibuster
within a month of taking office which
means the Republican minority won't be
able to stop it just the Democrats
together will be able to do it on
immigration I think you will see a
massive open borders proposal all
designed to ensure Democratic control so
the 12 13 14 million people here
illegally I think Democrats will grant
every one of them amnesty and try to
give them citizenship as quickly as
possible because they believe that that
most of those people here illegally will
vote Democratic and that's designed to
ensure they're controlling and just to
underscore that you know we're sitting
here in California California for a long
time was the heart of the Republican
Party California had voted in six
consecutive presidential elections
Republicans California had given us
Ronald Reagan Richard Nixon in 1987
Congress passed the last amnesty
proposal three million people here
illegally grant
amnesty the last election California
ever voted Republican was 1988 the year
after that and Mistie proposal it has
gone democratic rats take control they
will in ever to do that in the whole
country so that no Republican can can
win again I also think there's a very
good possibility that they vote to stack
the Supreme Court so you know one of the
areas where we're very grateful for the
victories we've had has been strong
constitutionalist judges on the court
you're seeing Democrats right now
embracing expanding the court from 9 to
15 if they have six Supreme Court
justices immediately you would see a
radical left wing Court and and all of
that look one of the problems the left
they're all in they believe in this
crazy stuff you know Bernie and Carmel
Harris we're talking what a few weeks
ago about the need to give every
convicted murderer the right to vote now
let me ask you Ben who in their right
mind looks at the United States of
America and said you know what our
democratic process needs Charles
Manson's voting like that is bat-crap
crazy but they're all in on this the
problem when Republicans when we have
unified control you know you know we're
sort of like like like Thurston Howell
oh my goodness we wouldn't wanna do
anything like that no no we're in a
cricket match no no no like we need to
have the same focus the same zealot re4
freedom that the left test for
government that's the fundamental fight
and and and I think if they take control
particularly if they get the Senate to
it is unbelievably dangerous in a second
don't ask your final question which is I
need to get your take on the Game of
Thrones finale because I know that
you're watching but if you actually want
to hear a Senator Cruz's answer you have
to be a daily wire subscriber subscribe
head on over to daily we're calm click
subscribe you can hear the end of our
conversation over there senator Cruz
thanks so much for stopping by I really
appreciate it good to see you sir good
to see
the Ben Shapiro show Sunday special is
produced by Jonathan hey executive
producer Jeremy boring associate
producer Mathis Glover edited by Donovan
Fowler audio is mixed by Dylan case hair
and makeup is by Jessa
alvera title graphics by Cynthia Angulo
the Ben Shapiro shows Sunday special is
a daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 19